Junior Jammu is rarely outside
he stared at the same Four Walls of a
hospital room for nine months
Junior has a neuromuscular condition is
unable to walk and breeds with the
assistance of a ventilator
he needs round-the-clock care
in my mind
it's frustrating
and I feel like
everybody don't care anyway
in may he was rushed to Saint Thomas's
Hospital in central London with sepsis
since September he's been medically fit
for discharge but he's still here
waiting for an appropriate care package
I can't even sleep most of the time
because I don't know what is going to
happen next away from hospital he will
be better and even improve but it has to
be with the right care package Junior
says some of his previous care wasn't
fit for purpose
an investigation launched by the London
Ambulance Service found that he may have
been at risk of neglect and was placed
at a risk that could have proven fatal
because everyday Consultants
a medical team
are saying the same things
that he needs no sled package
and I feel like I'm just being punished
the NHS care board in charge of Junior's
care says it takes an individual's needs
and circumstances into consultation with
them and their carers almost 13 and a
half thousand people in December who
were in hospital beds were considered
medically fit for discharge but more
than half of those require ongoing acute
treatment and around 15 percent need end
of life care what we know is that many
of those people will still have very
complex needs and they'll need a whole
range of services out in the community
in their own homes ideally so we often
hear that there are 13 000 people
waiting in hospital for social care
that's just not the case
Junior doesn't know when he will be able
to leave hospital he remains fit for
discharge but with no way out Ashish
Joshy Sky News in central London